[Music]
so
the following program contains the
opinions of its hosts
and guests not those of this network the
opinions expressed are for
non-commercial informational purposes
only
listeners are cautioned not to rely on
program content
to treat or prevent disease but are
advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth
dr joel wallach
[Music]
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie
dr joel wallach your host a veterinarian
and physician
and i'm here for kids and baby boomers
and seniors who don't want to die at
75.5 like their parents and grandparents
i'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to be sick and
miserable for the last 15 to 20 years
their life like their parents and
grandparents
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free one triple eight three seven
nine
two five five two again that's toll free
one triple eight three seven nine
two five five two well it looks like the
the covet 19 is quieting down a little
bit
okay uh it's gone from 75 000 to
infections every day down to about
28 000 to 50 000 now depending on the
day
so it's going down that's the right
direction and the deaths have gone from
maybe a couple of thousand
a day down to 600 to 900 to a thousand a
day so that's going down
and um you know we have established all
kinds of
very interesting things one of which was
a relationship with patch adams you know
the very famous
medical doctor patch adams who has been
a kid's advocate
and actually he's a family practitioner
but he's he's
recognized as a kid's advocate for kids
who are really in serious
health issues and so forth and you know
that you know
i'm feeling good and and having a laugh
and so forth even when you're
in a crisis is a good thing and so patch
adams you know has set the standard
uh for mental health and kids and
families and things like that so we're
so proud to have an association with him
and there's going to get more and wider
and deeper
and so stay tuned for that piece now
let's look at the pandemic a little bit
more here
um uh it's kind of like we're i think
we're going to exceed the number of dead
and sick
that came out in the spanish flu in 1918
okay we're going to have more infections
and more deaths
for instance india is going up um
350 000 to 500 000 new infections per
day
and so every three days are going up a
million infections
we're going up okay at 25 000 to
maybe 50 000 a day now and it had been
50 000 75 thousand per day so it's going
down a little bit
and i wanna go back to the days of the
spanish flu
and the uh asian flu
and hiv and uh things like uh
oh measles uh also things like
polio and then there is h1n1 and sars
and mers and
covid ii and
you're getting a picture here that like
every year there's a pandemic of course
there was the annual flu
it came along and no matter people
taking vaccinations they still had
maybe 30 40 000 people who die every
year
now i'm going to ask a question um did
they have the ability to really
they say okay these people died of the
flu because they were dying of the
symptoms of the flu
but how many of those were covered 19.
the reason was called covet 19 because
they identified the virus in
2019 and so
how long have that virus been around is
it part of the
deaths in the spanish flu in 1918 has
been part
of aids and hiv um
we don't know okay all we know is that
right now
this is the deadliest thing we got going
on
all right and so um we have to look at
all this and get put things in
perspective
so let's look at again some numbers some
realistic numbers here
um let's look at the the world this is
as of this morning the world 167 million
544 270
new infections deaths in the world
as of this morning three million four
hundred and seventy eight thousand nine
hundred and fifty three
let's look at the usa okay the usa
we have the highest rate of infections
and deaths in the world
we're 33 million ninety six thousand
assuming eight hundred ninety six
thousand
eight hundred sixty infections and six
hundred four thousand nine hundred
twelve
dead now let's look at india
the most populous country in the world
india
had 20 million die of the spanish flu
okay in two years actually over a six
month period
they had 110 million new infections of
the spanish flu in in 1918
okay and so right now they're spiking
big time
okay in india as of this morning
there are 26 million 718 thousand
108 infections and three hundred and two
thousand dead now they're 1.7 billion
people we have 332
million people here in america and so
what's going on here
well uh india has two populations which
we've discussed before
the northern nine states have the
highest rate 95 percent of the deaths
and 87
infections the southern 20 states and
seven territories
have only five percent of the deaths
and 17 of the infections
and that's because in the south they
live on rice and sweet potatoes and corn
and
beans and squash and seaweed and the
north they live on wheat broth rhinos
because the british
occupied them for a hundred years um
making their young men soldiers to fight
the world wars and everything
they're part of the commonwealth okay
and so it's one of those things where um
india is in big trouble because of their
diet not because there are
homogenous people it's just they're
different between the north and the
south because of what they eat
okay in the south they live like asians
and the north they live like europeans
uh diet wise same thing is true
uh with the philippines versus vietnam
philippines has 100 million people
vietnam has 97 million
vietnam has 39 dead and the philippines
have 1 000
excuse me nineteen thousand six hundred
forty one dead
okay almost twenty thousand did they
have one million
one hundred sixty five thousand
infections and
the philippines have
four thousand 4809 infections hello
back after these messages you're
listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the cbs radio
network with your host
dr joel wallach if you'd like to talk to
dr wallet call between noon and 1
pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
the antioxidants found in many fruits
and vegetables
are known to help support and promote
good health research
has also shown that dark chocolate once
known as the food of the gods
is rich in healthy nutrients in fact
dark chocolate is higher in antioxidant
content
than any other food youngevity has
combined a proprietary blend of velvety
rich dark chocolate
with whole fruit pulp and whole fruit
juice extracts from mangosteen
goji or wolfberry acai berry and cherry
along with vitamins and minerals
producing a smooth
rich delectable concentrate called
coconutty
it tastes so great i sometimes drink it
right out of the bottle
or pour it over ice cream coconutty is
highly bioavailable
meaning your body will absorb and make
use of all of these healthy nutrients
if you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
in recent years several studies have
discovered the healthy benefits of
drinking coffee
youngevity has now taken it a step
further with an entire product line of
healthy coffees
from youngevity's java fit selection of
top shelf gourmet coffees
all java fit coffees are made from 100
premium hand-selected arachaba coffee
beans
grown in the finest regions of latin
america
all are carefully roasted creating a
delicious
rich full-bodied flavor for an extra
boost try java fits energy extreme
62 a proprietary blend of nutrients
including
cambogia green tea extract an extra shot
of caffeine
and niacin designed to support
metabolism
and enhanced physical performance
available in single cup
or single pot packs contact your local
youngevity distributor to get job
pollution coffees
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity back
with
dead doctors don't lie on the cbs radar
network dr joel walk here for youngevity
and 95 crusade we do have lines open
give us a call toll free one triple
eight three seven nine two five five two
again that's toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two
and again i'll give you a couple of
comparisons here let's look at uh
australia versus texas they both have
about 26 million
27 million people and
let's see here australia has 910 dead
um texas has 51 000 dead
australia has 30 000 infections uh uh
texas has 2.9 million infections so
what's the difference
well 41 percent of australia's
indigenous peoples
39 of texas are latinos and it is eight
percent
uh 14 of texas is um
black okay it's a diet thing
okay in texas it's a diet thing
because people who eat uh gluten wheat
butter and oats
the latinos and the blacks and the
asians and the indigenous peoples and so
forth
they have the highest rates of
infections and deaths okay because it
kills
their intestines their villi they can't
absorb nutrients
and if you're not supplementing
nutrients and you can't absorb what
little may be in the food
you're in big trouble your bone marrow
is going to die you're going to get bone
marrow dysplasia
and you are not going to be able to
respond appropriately to the vaccination
so if you want to appropriately
respond to the vaccination you better be
getting rid of the gluten out of your
life and taking the 90 cents of
nutrients
so your bone marrow will work okay
otherwise the vaccines are
not good okay let's look at louisiana
versus new zealand
okay i both have about the same
population five million people louisiana
of course the french came down from
canada when they got kicked out by the
english in the 1800s
and so um the in new zealand they have
dead 26 dead in louisiana they have 10
dead remember they got the same
population 5 million
new zealand has 2 600 infections
louisiana has 465 000
infections what's the difference well
again louisiana
has about 35 percent of the population
is a mix of latinos and blacks
and so because of their diet not their
race
because their diet they're lifting the
numbers of infections and deaths
okay so when you look at the peoples
in the united states as let's say the
top three states
california texas and florida when it
comes to
covet california has 39 latinos and
eight percent
black texas has 39 latinos and 14
black florida has 25
latinos and 18 black so um
they're all over 40 okay of these
of these minority peoples in their
population
and they primarily eat wheat brought
around oats okay
flour tortillas spaghetti pancakes
waffles french toast
fried chicken kentucky fried chicken all
that kind of stuff
okay and so they're paying a price these
peoples are not famous for supplementing
so it's an education process to get them
off all the bad foods
and supplement properly so we can save
as many as we can
okay and we're looking for help and of
course we pay very well
in these days and times you've lost your
job you've been laid off you want to
really contact your young zibi associate
and say i'm in i want to help save
people and make some money at the same
time
okay doug what pearls wisdom do you have
for us well i've got a story here
headlined
flaxseed proteins are great sources of
antioxidant peptides according to a
study from new zealand and canada
where they analyze the storage proteins
of mature flaxseed and hopes of
discovering new antioxidant peptides and
they found that
flaxseed is high in protein and flaxseed
is also a great source of antioxidant
peptides
these uh protein fragments typically
consist of two to twenty amino acids
because of their ability to scavenge
free radicals and chelate metals
antioxidant peptides present a promising
solution for
reducing oxidative stress and
controlling the oxidization of foods and
that is lipids in foods and cosmetic
products say oxidative
stress is a phenomenon uh caused by an
imbalance between the generation of free
radicals and the production of
antioxidants inside the body so there
you go get you some flaxseed going
well yeah and of course it's not a big
crop in the united states okay
uh flex is not it's not a big crop in
the united states
so we actually have started um with
grape seed
extract grapes grape seed extract
it has the same um
biochemical map as flax seed
so watch for that because our grape seed
extract is coming out
in soft gel caps and also dropper
bottles
holy moly and we'll be back after these
messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs
radio network with your host dr joel
wallick if you'd like to talk to dr
wallach call between noon and 1 pacific
at 831 685
toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself youngevity's beyond tangy
tangerine
a blend of plant-derived minerals
combined with vitamins amino acids and
other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives
and it's glycemic friendly each scoop of
the nutri crystals contain
equal amounts of all the nutrients it
starts out as a liquid
then is freeze dry to ensure each scoop
has the same nutrients
as the last scoop so if you want to get
your hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count
on the go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this great
multivitamin and mineral product
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity
hello judy divilbus here if i could only
afford
to get one product out of everything
that product would be the ultimate
classic
it has the vitamins the minerals the
bioflavonoids it even has grape seed
extract
the one product that would give you just
about everything under the sun you would
need for a perfect
nutritional program would be the
ultimate classic
by the way people that are on the go
it's very very hard
to take the liquids with them when they
go on their trip to get their
supplements in every day
well you know something you can use the
ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules
when i'm going on a trip if i have
enough room i just take the two bottles
with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple
it's very easy there's no mess no fuss
no refrigeration
just take your capsules take your
tablets and you're finished for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today
if your doctor is telling you that you
can get all the nutrients you need to
stay healthy
well that's just wrong dr joel wallick
has identified 90 essential nutrients
that the human body needs to thrive
crops only need
three nutrients to thrive so where does
your doctor
think the other 87 nutrients come from
they don't
so if you're not supplementing you're
starving your body
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine will
get you a long way
down the road to getting those 90
essential nutrients
beyond tangy tangerine contains
plant-derived minerals combined with
vitamins amino acids
and other beneficial nutrients beyond
tangy tangerine is a balanced and
complete
daily supplement so if you want to give
your body the nutrients it needs
order beyond tangy tangerine today
contact your local youngevity associate
to order this product and don't forget
to ask about
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with jed doctors don't lie on
the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for youngevity 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free
five five two
and uh shari there i'm here
okay well um i want to know why michigan
has the highest death rate okay of
any state we've already talked about it
because we have
all these micro breweries here where the
micro
brewery capital of the whole united
states
and maybe the world maybe the world yeah
could be
yeah who would have thunk it years ago
really
yeah well how many what do you think
about supplementation is
are the people of michigan a
supplementing state do they you know
they all run around with vitamins
minerals in their hands
um you know i really don't know the
answer to that question
just depends on the people i guess the
way they were brought up and everything
and so they're kind of you know michigan
is kind of a mixed state a lot of
manufacturing a lot of factories and
stuff like that but it does have some
agriculture correct
we have quite a bit of agriculture
actually you know
uh traverse city michigan is supposed to
be the cherry capital of the world
uh you know other cherry cherries
black cherries and red cherries and
we have okay cherry festival how many
how many minerals do cherries make
only what's in the ground okay yeah they
collected out of the ground but they
don't make any
and we have a friend of ours remember
that thinks everything
is in wine that should be and the
person's got two different kinds of
cancer right now
because he thought wine was gonna save
him and it won't
it didn't it's not gonna
yeah okay well wine has potential has
some antioxidant properties in it and
has a place
but um if you just want to be
comfortable as you're dying well that's
just a good thing to do
right but you kind of
tranquilize yourself as a wine um
but um basically if you really really
really
want to prevent these diseases and add
25 to 50 healthier life
what's the basic recipe char for people
who want to add 25 to 50 healthy years
their life
well i mean the basic is a healthy start
pack everybody
everybody should be on a healthy start
pack per 100 pounds of body weight
and if they did they would definitely
and you know and you
know when you see as we've gotten older
you can see
people uh some people die so young and
you it's sad really but you
understand why when you see how they eat
and
don't take care of themselves and they
don't use your castle and think you're
gonna it's gonna stay standing it won't
yeah good point yeah and so that's the
truth you know you look at people in
your family all have the same genetic
background
okay and yet um one arm
or one leg if you will of the family
they all die young
if you look at what they eat it's
totally different from the leg of the
family that lives
you know twice as long and it has to do
exactly as you say charmaine everything
is what you eat what you don't eat
and you know what's the only way to
guarantee you're going to get all 90
essential nutrients
income i mean you can't it's certainly
not in the food we know that
i mean people joke about the crappy food
and it's really not a joking matter it's
a serious
issue and it's life and death it is
and you it depends on i guess how much
you want to live and i
you have to come to the conclusion and
accept the fact that everybody really
doesn't want to live a long life
and well to me to me it's worth
you know five bucks a day at 25 to
50 years of your life a healthful years
you know five bucks a day come on
we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the cbs
radio network with your host dr joel
wallach
if you'd like to talk to dr wallach call
between noondan 1 pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr wallace
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevity's
beyond tangy tangerine a blend of plant
derived minerals combined with vitamins
amino acids
and other beneficial nutrients this
all-natural product contains no starch
wheat or yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives
and it's glycemic friendly each scoop of
the nutri
contain equal amounts of all the
nutrients it starts out as a liquid
then is freeze dry to ensure each scoop
has the same nutrients
as the last scoop so if you want to get
your hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild
youngevities beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity
over 10 years ago we realized how
important saving family memories was
and we wanted to help legacy box started
from that passion
and has now helped over 850 000 families
digitally preserve their film reels vhs
tapes and photos
hi i'm nick and i'm adam what started
with the two of us in a garage is now
over 200 trained professionals legacy
box is a safe and secure way to put all
your favorite family memories on an easy
to view
digital format like a thumb drive dvd or
the cloud we ship you a sturdy legacy
box to fill with all your outdated media
safety barcodes to track your items
throughout the process and a prepaid
mailing label legacy box has been
featured by good morning america and the
today show not bad for two kids in a
garage
that's true nick and here's the best
part we always wanted to make it
affordable to preserve your entire
collection
so we are offering 40 off go to
legacybox.com
lbox to take advantage of this exclusive
offer that's legacybox.com
lbox to save forty percent legacy box
dot com slash
l box if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself youngevity's beyond tangy
tangerine
a blend of plant derived minerals
combined with vitamins amino acids and
other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives and
it's glycemic friendly each scoop of the
nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients
it starts out as a liquid then is freeze
dry to ensure each scoop
has the same nutrients as the last scoop
so if you want to get your hands on a
quality nutritional supplement designed
to give the body the raw materials it
needs to rebuild
youngevities beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count
on the go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this great
multivitamin and mineral product and
don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the zbs radio network dr joel wallet
care for youngevity 90 flight crusade we
do have lines open give us a call toll
free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two and i just want to urge
everybody
it's actually much much cheaper to eat
well
than it is eat badly it's much much much
cheaper
to supplement with 90 essential
nutrients than it is to
spend money and time to go to the
doctors all the time
okay and this is something you can
control
you don't need to ask permission from
the government or anything like that
okay
it's one of those things where you can
control it but i do ask you to go to our
website
www.drjwalik.com www.drjwalik.com
we have 15 books we have over 100 cds
i don't know dozens of of audio cassette
tapes
we have i think more than 50 dvds
okay a lot of information there and it's
worth the investment
and if you sign up as a young giving
associate
okay uh any of these tools these books
and cds and dvds you purchase
their tax write-off if you use them in
your in your business library
and of course if you buy uh 10 or 50 of
the cds and dvds you get a discount you
buy cases of books you get discounts
and then people who are really
interested
in joining you in the longevity business
or as a patient
will want this information and you can
sell to them and make a you know a few
extra bucks
by passing on the information it's only
going to get better because
when our relationship with patch adams
oh my
gosh okay doug let's go to callers
all right let's head to new york and
david you're on with dr wallach
oh david you're on the air how can we
help you
yeah so i'm 38 years old i'm six feet
190 pounds
i went to the ophthalmologist today to
follow up for a corneal abrasion which
thankfully healed
but uh she told me i had large optic
nerves
and that i was a glaucoma suspect i may
have been
born with it but they want to run
further tests so i want to know
um you know what what can i do you know
the naturopathic approach to uh
sure that's my eye health okay now first
of all
um let's see here do you have any other
issues any highlight pressure or
diabetes
oh no that's normal okay no issue there
how about things like balance problems
or tinnitus ringing in the ears anything
going on there
oh no okay good have you lost your sense
of smell or you're still okay there
no i have my sense of smell okay any low
back problem you know sciatica numbness
tingling in the toes numbness tingling
in the hands
anything like that
um sometimes i get numbness in my arm
when i'm
when i was sleeping
when i wake up i feel sometimes a little
numb maybe i sleep on my arm i'm not
sure
okay and then uh any skin issues any
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
yeah okay so which one
eczema okay and any asthma or bronchitis
no okay good any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea
irritable bowel syndrome celiac disease
diverticulitis anything like that
oh my i get the diarrhea but i haven't
you know i stay away from gluten so that
that's helped a lot
okay good uh did you have your attack
when you're a kid conditions
no yeah oh yeah okay good well the skin
conditions
okay charmaine are you there i'm here
yes
okay so what's david's problem you know
he has a history
of you know skin problems and diarrhea
and
all kind of stuff yeah that's definitely
a gluten problem no question about it
and he gave up gluten and he's better
and so when he
when we come back we're going to talk
about his optic nerves when we come
back
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie
on the cbs
radio network with your host dr joel
wallick if you'd like to talk to dr
wallach call us toll-free
[Music]
[Applause]
888-379-2552
[Music]
[Applause]
hi registered pharmacist ben fuchs here
i've been studying healthy bodies for 35
years and what i've got to tell you may
shock and surprise you but if you listen
up
it may change your life the gallbladder
is a little biological bag designed to
hold bile in preparation for digestion
of fats and it's a favorite target for
surgical removal
over half a million of them are yanked
out a patient's abdomens every year
although doctors will tell you that you
can live just fine without the bag of
bile as it turns out nothing could be
further from the truth
bile is the key player in the processing
of dietary fats and while it's true that
some of the fat dissolving biochemical
detergent can be squirted onto food
directly from the liver without a
gallbladder it's going to be much more
difficult for the digestive system
processing and absorption of numerous
nutrients including fats and essential
fatty acids vitamins and thousands of
plant chemicals that play a key role in
health healing and anti-aging in fact
without this little sack of tissue
you're going to run higher risks for
pretty much any health condition you can
name
digestive issues including gastritis and
chronic diarrhea are particularly likely
and not surprising possible side effect
so are skin issues like psoriasis and
eczema
and you may have to deal with
hyperpigmentation and accelerated aging
too
even cancer is on the short list for
post gallbladder removal misery best way
to prevent gallbladder problems is to
eliminate problem foods and improve
digestion
food intolerances are typically
associated with gallstone formation
using a good probiotic and eating
fermented foods can be helpful
consider lecithin and bile salts after
fatty meals because gallbladder issues
can impair the absorption of fatty
nutrients you're going to want to make
sure you're supplementing with essential
fatty acids fatty vitamins
and minerals farms has been here urging
you to go to kscohealth.com to order
beyond tangy tangerine the healthy start
pack and
other nutritional supplements that i
personally use and recommend
you can purchase these premium quality
products at wholesale prices online at
ksco health.com that's kscohealth.com
i'm a pharmacist that believes that
staying healthy and strong is not only
about medicine it's about giving your
body the raw materials it needs to do
its work
go to kscohealth.com make sure you check
out the cool videos too
at ksco health.com that's ksco health
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back with jed doctors don't lie on
the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for youngevity 95 crusade we do
headlines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two again that's toll
free one triple eight three seven nine
two five five two okay so we've got
people waiting we're gonna go right back
to david in new york
and um let's see here
with his enlarged optic nerve have you
slowly over the years
had to increase the strength of your
eyeglasses or had the prescription
changed in any way
um no uh my my vision
actually improved a little bit my right
eye is 20 20.
my left is 20 30.
okay very good all right
um okay
so uh charmaine what would you do for
david here he's um
190 pounds he has his history and you
pinpointed it early before he went to
the break that he has
you know everybody has a gluten problem
but he really you know had a lot of
clinical stuff with the diarrhea and
okay all right and so forth i would
well um i would get him on to healthy
brain and heart packs because of his
weight and that would
add to that msm ultimate daily classic
vitamin d3 for absorption and
for his i'll get him on the
oculative too for his eyes
one of those twice today is two vowels
one there's only 30 in a bottle and of
course the vision effects he could take
three of those twice a day
and um yeah i believe he's got some
osteoporosis to the skull
squeezing that optic nerve there's an
artery that travels with it from the
brain
along the optic nerve into the eye and
then the veins in the eye come back
along
the optic nerve back into the brain and
so there's
there's um a lot of history
of people with enlarged optic nerves and
endemius optic nerves there's a lot of
edema and stuff in them
because the skull is squeezing them and
they return from the eye
of the blood is slowed down by the skull
squeezing
that nerve and the veins and the
arteries okay
and so um in every case you should see
some benefit here
but you're going to have to be like
really really really
no gluten everybody in the household dog
fish cat bird renter roommate spouse
everybody's got to be dropped
gluten-free so there's no
cross-contamination in the laundry in
the food preparation services beds
couches
rugs all that kind of stuff but give us
a call every couple of weeks
just following that little recipe shard
through at you will do good and if you
didn't get it
doug will post it when the show is done
here so you can
get at it constantly okay doug let's go
to callers
said to california and madrid you're on
with dr wallach
well hello my drew how can we help you
hi dr wallace i have a four year old i
have a four-year-old boy
he's about 32 pounds
and he's getting styes
and his parents are worried about it
that's the only thing that's going on
okay so he's him in high trouble yes
yes and he's always you know up in his
eyes
okay does he have any skin problems
um just you know like you know
what you're just rubbing you know
on the eye area there that's it okay he
rubs his scalp
uh sometimes but pretty much against the
uh
yeah okay so does he have any bowel
problems
you know constipation does he have
diarrhea anything like that
uh no not really not really but they're
just concerned about the size and the
itching in the skin
and everything so i was telling women so
basically they want information yeah
and so if there's any blood tests been
done we'd like to know the results of
the blood test that would be interesting
but also i would get a hair analysis on
this kid
okay okay okay you know how to do that
you could go to the book
uh where earth medicare's chapter 110
right
get that hair sample in we'll find out
if he's absorbing
we'll find out if this is a gluten issue
which it probably is
okay because of the itching skin right
and so he's a candidate
okay good yeah he's probably a candidate
for you know appendicitis and all that
kind of stuff
um and so um is he a kid of color or is
he a white guy or what
his caucasian yes okay so
um i was thinking about uh you know the
vitiligo like michael jackson had that
kind of stuff
okay so anyway yeah and so we need to
get him he's
um 32 pounds what supplement program
would you give him charmaine
he's 132 pounds you said no no no just
32 pounds
oh okay oh okay well then he i'd get him
on a healthy brain and hard pack but uh
he don't need the whole thing i'd just
get him on uh
half a do a quarter of those twice a day
okay and then i would add um
i would add the msm
and the ultimate daily classic to that
and what what about efas yeah well
that's in the pack
yeah okay if asia needs to take the face
yeah he needs to take the efas that are
in the pack yes
and also if he's not big on taking
capsules and he fights taking all those
capsules and everything
he could use the kids toddy okay just go
by body weight
on the kids right okay and but don't
forget the efas
and then of course we have the liquid
calcium right we have the liquid
um cucoid z called z radical
and so that's another option is the
liquid z
radical um the cucoid z
the liquid calcium the kids tidy and the
efas
and the f8 pluses and so those are two
options
but char you know you're going to get a
lot more um
nutrition in the healthy brain and heart
pack a quarter would dose twice a day
right sure is exactly correct yeah but
if he fights you
then you got to go the other direction
at least for a while and then squeeze
your face and put them in the liquid
yeah put them in a juice or something
like i do with my little baby
okay all right so keep in touch with us
on this one andrew um you know let us
know how this goes and get the hair
analysis
and i'd be very interested to see that
here analysis okay
okay thank you dr wallace god bless you
okay yeah kids um you know i'm not big
on
with needles 10 times in a doctor's
visit or something like that so a hair
analysis gives you a lot of information
on their nutritional status as well as
if they're absorbing it all
okay and so we need to know that and so
a hair analysis is really a good place
to start
and of course i'm sure he you know gets
some blood work done when he goes to the
doctor
um and of course it never hurts to pay
attention
uh because these kids you know they'll
get to be six seven eight years old to
get an
appendicitis attack because they had all
these gluten issues
okay douglas go to callers said to
minnesota and john you're on with dr
wallach
john you're on the air if you've got
time for two questions
one is my ponytail got cut off about a
week ago how fresh does the hair have to
be to send it in to
have an alice done we we do um
hair analyses on three thousand year old
mummies so
okay great next question uh
i got uh um
surgery for uh um hernias and they took
blood work and my
creatinine is 2.3 and
they want me to go on dialysis
okay are you urinating
yes not much at a time but all night
all day okay what every hour kind of
thing
uh 40 minutes to an hour and a half okay
any back problems
yes my lower back is killing me
okay so this part of that may be due to
um the back squeezing the
um spinal nerves that control the
bladder and all that kind of stuff so
that's that's going on there too
okay and so charmaine how much do you
weigh john
down to 130 pounds and i'm 5'4 i've
shrunk an inch and a half
and uh i'm wondering how low i can go
i'm eating the soft coats eggs and i
don't eat chill but
how old are you how old are you 68 my
dad died okay
okay well we're not gonna let you die so
hang on we'll be back and get your pen
and paper ready
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie
on the cbs radio network with your host
dr
joel wallick
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
earth's oceans
we do know that the oceans and seas are
still abundant with life
and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures have
long believed in the life-giving
properties of plants
and sea life harvested from the oceans
young japanese oceans gold
is a proprietary blend of seaweeds
algaes
mosses kelp sea cucumbers and sea
minerals
as well as coenzyme q10 calcium
and iron all designed to help support
healthy thyroid function
regular heartbeat normal weight mood
stabilization
and hormone levels take advantage of
life-sustaining nutrients from the
earth's oceans
with youngevities oceans gold if you'd
like to learn more about nutritional
supplementation
call your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
hey if you're like me your life is
hectic you don't know where you're gonna
be next
between kids and family and in-laws and
work and traffic and everything else
that's driving me crazy right now
my life is insane i bet your life's
insane as well when do we have time to
get every single nutrient we need to be
healthy when
well i've got a tip for you take a
product called pollen burst
it's so simple even i can do it all you
have to do is open the package
pour it in water mix it up and bam
you're ready to go
it tastes great it's not one of those
medicine tasting things it tastes great
low in calories helps curb your appetite
gives you natural energy that doesn't
let you crash
gives your vitamins minerals nutrients
everything from the plant world and i
gotta tell you for a busy person like me
or a busy person like you we need
simple we need good palm versus your
answer
taste great try it and you'll feel
better call
your local youngevity distributor to
find out how pollenverse can make you
feel better
and don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
if weight loss is your goal try
youngevity slender fx keto caramel
weight management bars
and shake designed to enhance any low
carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing
and filling protein dieters need without
unhealthy
excess carbs a keto diet known for its
low carb
intake pushing the body to produce
ketones from fat used as
energy a state known as ketosis
by using fat not carbohydrates as fuel
in this metabolic state a keto diet
supports and promotes
healthy weight management for optimal
health
with this system you should be able to
lose one
to two pounds each day
so what are you waiting for start
helping people today
with your own home-based business
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for young duty 95 crusade and
charmaine what would you do for john
okay he's you know had a herding
operation he's got low back problems
um i would get him on a healthy brain
and hard pack but i would also add to
it the
ultimate daily classic very important
and some msn for regrowing tissues and
muscle and everything
and uh vitamin d3 for absorption
hello stop for a minute yup i want to
make sure that he knows that he should
be taking three of those ultimate daily
classic challenge three times a day
purpose is to support healthy blood
pressure but more importantly here
to support healthy blood flow through
that kidney and
his kidney function will probably come
back very quickly within weeks
so that he shouldn't have to go on
dialysis i take people that haven't
urinated in 10 years
and put them on this program the char is
laying out for you and in two weeks time
they're urinating so they went down from
six times a week to three times a week
and two more weeks are totally off with
dialysis
so most of the time i don't know ninety
percent of the time you can get off the
dialysis
by taking this program that shar is
talking about okay
um the health abandoned heart pack i
would also add another bottle of art
selenium so you can take
three over selenium twice a day and a
half a dose of everything else
twice a day and then don't forget the
ultimate daily classic tablets of char
said
uh three of those with each meal is
three bottles a month and
um the msm three of those twice a day
and
i would also throw in the collagen
um okay peptides okay let's see here
give us a call every couple of weeks
we'll walk you through this john
you're gonna have a miracle testimony
okay do we have time for another one
here doug yeah let's head to north
carolina and david you're on with dr
wallach
hello david you're on the air hi what's
up
okay fellow vet
okay appreciate your service
oh i appreciate your sir um
the uh the thing is i'm calling about a
uh a person
that they were born with six fingers
okay
is that could you explain that as uh you
know like
on a mineral standpoint for you know a
deficiency or
yes well it's a birth defect as you
point out
and it's not unusual there's babies born
with three legs there's a baby barn with
one eye and
you know kind of cycloptic sort of thing
um
there's babies they're born with no arms
and no legs there's babies born with
sickle cell anemia and there's babies
born with spina bifida and
all kind you know cleft palate all these
things are caused by
nutrients missing during pregnancy
when the fingers are forming there can
either be a stimulus
to grow more or a deficiency to grow
less
and so it's just a matter of you know i
i would like to know what the mom was
doing
uh so forth and get a hair analysis of
that mother and see what's going on
there but when you have extra digits or
extra toes
it's not uncommon it's actually quite
common
to have extra toes and fingers but it's
a birth defect caused by a nutritional
deficiency okay stimulating the dna
to do something extraordinary okay
that's a great question okay
and here's and here's where you want to
make sure that everybody in your family
who's in the child bearing years
if they're taking the 90 well i'm eating
well no that's not good enough you need
to be taking the 90s
nutrients avoid the glutens they can
maximize absorption
and we can reduce the risk of all these
birth defects where things are missing
too many things are there and so on
um there are no gently transmitted birth
defects
there are no jaguar transfer diseases
and that's what my thesis for ten
i was giving me for 20 000 autopsies is
in the smithsonian institute as a
national treasure
because they showed very clearly there
were all of these birth defects
were caused by nutritional deficiencies
not
genetics there are no genetically
transmitted birth defects
whether you're having too many legs and
toes and eyes or not enough
eyes and toes and legs okay um
is always a deficiency of a nutrient
and so are maybe multiple nutrients okay
and your body
tries to react one way or another and
it's kind of crazy
um and you know we're going to probably
come out with a book here
um uh where we
where we show all these different birth
defects and what causes them but it's a
great question thank you so much david
okay well thank you everybody great
stuff today don't forget your 90s stay
away from the bad stuff
add 25 to 50 health for years your life
make some lives
we'll be back another day tomorrow god
bless each and every one of you god
bless our troops god bless our navy
seals god bless the american flag god
bless our national anthem
and god bless america
bye